to understand this a little bit more
let's take a look at a very unique
scenario let's say we have a happy
little tank trudging along through a war
zone the tank randomly fires a bullet
into the air which is actually aimed at
a bunch of little enemy soldiers camping
out in the environment the tank itself
has a small amount of hit points say
three or so and the mortar in flight
will actually destroy all of these
awesome little enemy soldiers over here
the question for you then is this which
updates first in your update loop let's
say for instance the infantry update
first well this frame the infantry will
shoot at the tank and kill the tank and
then the bullet will update killing the
infantry this would actually create a
level playing field an alternative
scenario whoever is what if the bullet
updates first the bullet would actually
kill the infantry and they wouldn't have
time to update and kill the tank in this
solution the tank itself will actually
be pretty happy trudging along through
the war zone now there's not really a
good pattern to attack all this most
networked RTS games actually allow this
to occur quite blindly and simply ensure
that all of the clients in the
simulation have the same ordering of
entities this ensures that one client
doesn't update infantry then bullet then
tank and the other one do tank then
bullet then infantry I've also seen some
games take a different approach to it in
a bucket eyes manner so for instance you
may go ahead and bucket eyes and say
that all of your infantry update first
and then all of your tanks and then all
of your bullets if you ensure this
grouped ordering of entities this allows
you to have the infantry get the upper
hand on tanks which gets the upper hand
on those evil evil bullets with this
layout the infantry would update first
killing the tank and then the bullet
would update this frame killing the
infantry leaving a level playing field
for next frame